bezahlte trolle desinformation social
bots und leaks immer wieder gerät
russland in diesem zusammenhang in
verdacht und experten sind sich einig
der kampf um die internationale macht
und vorherrschaft wird von der
russischen regierung ins netz verlagert
manche vermuten eine ganze fake news
maschinen travel und die große gefahr
ist mehr als offensichtlich die
öffentliche meinung wird manipuliert
wahlen beeinflusst und die stimmung wird
aufgeheizt mal sehen was hier unter dem
video so passiert manche nennen es schon
den krieg des 21 jahrhunderts was und
wer genau dahinter steckt viele
spannende beispiele dafür
und wie gefährdet wir in deutschland
wirklich sind jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
übrigens am ende des videos gibt es eine
gratis seid gespannt
im internet gelten andere regeln als in
der echten welt das netz wird zunehmend
zum spielfeld eine auseinandersetzung
die militärexperten mittlerweile als
krieg bezeichnen waffen und ziele
bestehen hier aus informationen es gibt
schätzungen nach denen dieser krieg mehr
als 10.000 tote und millionen
vertriebene zur folge hat ein krieg den
der stellvertretende
us-verteidigungsminister bob burg in
einer rede 2015 als labor für die
kriegsführung des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts genannt hat einer der sich
an dem krieg der von tastaturen
ausgeführt wird beteiligt ist neo man
sah ein aktivist aus donetsk etwa 50
jahre alt der alle seine freizeit auf
verschiedenen russischen zwischen
medienseiten verbringt dies kennt der
durch und hört zudem prorussische
funkkanäle ab ich kann nicht als soldat
kämpfen also versuche ich auf diese
weise mein bestes zu tun sagt er
auch im fall einer 17 waren leute wie er
in gewisser weise verstrickt eine stunde
vor dem start der maschine am
amsterdamer flughafen schreibt eine
romanze auf twitter es ähnelt stark an
der bug also einem mobilen russischen
boden luft raketen system mit mittlerer
reichweite
konkret kann sich um eine 34 tonnen
schwere book m1 teller
das steht für transporter auf richter
trägerrakete und radar das waffensystem
wird begleitet von ihren lehrern truppen
eine halbe stunde später die ma 17 ist
längst gestartet und mittlerweile etwa
30 minuten in der luft jetzt meldet ein
ukrainischer aktivist etwa wh er habe
den konvoi durch die stadt tores
versehen etwa 45 meilen östlich von
dollars und in richtung der stadt
schnitt später wurde das system dann
tatsächlich in einem feld aufgestellt um
24 ortszeit feuerte es dann eine 1.500
kontrakte ab ist fast dreifacher
schallgeschwindigkeit stieg sie auf
33.000 fuß höhe ausgestattet war sie mit
einem 154 von schweren gefechtskopf der
etwa vier meter schräg links oberhalb
der flugzeugnase explodiert sein muss
ein fragment davon fanden die ermittler
bei der autopsie der 15 crewmitglieder
und der 283 passagiere im körper eines
besatzungsmitgliedes hunderte metall
fragmente fanden sie auch in der leiche
des kapitäns und 120 im körper eines
offiziers unter dem passagier
man im übrigen 80 kinder die
absturzstelle der immer 17 hat da ein
osze ermittler als den größten tatort
der welt bezeichnet wirklich mehr als
grausam und noch bis heute ist unklar
wer genau den knopf freigegeben hat die
russische regierung hat sich in diesem
fall immer weiter verstrickt die taktik
scheint zu sein kritiker unglaubwürdig
zu machen und von sich selbst abzulenken
hoch automatisierte netzwerke von bots
sorgen genauso wie bezahlte tolle dafür
dass anschuldigung und ablenkungsmanöver
massenhaft verbreitet werden eine breite
front die sich da aufgestellt hat ihre
gegner freiwillige die sozialen
netzwerke als ermittlungs grundlage
nehmen wie zum beispiel das crowdfunding
projekt berlin kat das drei tage vor dem
mhh 17 absturz gestartet war nicht
einmal sechs stunden nachdem emma 17
abgeschossen wurde hatte sein gründer
ein spannendes video gefunden es zeigt
wie die buck durchs nischen erfährt
genau dieses video findet zwei jahre
später seinen platz in dem
abschlussbericht des internationalen
untersuchungsteams das berlin kennt
netzwerk hat nur ein minimales budget
und trotzdem haben seine teilnehmer
unglaubliches geleistet auf social media
beiträgen und frei verfügbaren
satelliten fotos haben sie ihre
ergebnisse gewonnen unter anderem die
identifikation der burg einheit nummer
333 und das zugehörige bataillon der 53
flugabwehrraketen brigade in russland
dazu verglichen sie unzählige fotos und
fokussierten sich dabei auf
charakteristische merkmale wie beulen
und die anordnung von kabelverbindung
zum raketen auf richter die belling cat
aktivisten waren auch diejenigen die als
erstes öffentlich den weg beschrieben
haben denen die burg zurückgelegt hatte
ein ungleich höheres budget zur
aufklärung des ema 17 abschlusses hatte
natürlich das offizielle niederländische
ermittlungsteam der sicherheitsausschuss
zur verfügung gleich hunderte ermittler
vernahmen mehr als 200 zeugen und 1400
watt stücke wurden untersucht und eine
halbe million fotos und videos wurden
analysiert der kostenpunkt dafür 4,8
millionen us dollar
die vorläufigen ergebnisse des
sicherheitsausschusses gab es im
september letzten jahres demnach war
eine puk m1 teller von der russischen
föderation
die ukraine gebracht worden und feierte
dort die entscheidende rakete ab danach
wurde das waffensystem nach russland
zurückgebracht die russische antwort auf
diese enthüllung war allerdings eher
eine fast zunächst beschuldigte die
regierung einen ukrainischen kampfjet
dann waren ukrainische bodentruppen und
später auch die ci verantwortlich später
gab es dann noch die behauptung dass
eigentlich putins privatflugzeug das
ziel gewesen sei dass alles lief durch
eine art nebelmaschine troll farm
halbautomatische botnetze und die
russischen staatsmedien haben in diesem
kontext ganze arbeit geleistet
gleichzeitig wurde auch auf die gegner
geschossen es gab hacker-angriffe auf
den niederländischen
sicherheitsausschuss und spear phishing
angriffe auf das berlin cats netzwerk
und das war tatsächlich nur der auftakt
für ein weitaus größeres spiel es
folgten hacker-angriffe auf die nato
französische medien auf verschiedene
regierungen und die osze auch der
deutsche bundestag war betroffen immer
wieder tauchte dabei einnahme einer
bestimmten hackergruppe auf fancy bier
auch strontium und white oder zart ihm
genannt
sicherheitsexperten und experten
bezeichnen die gruppe als ep 28 laura
galante arbeitet für ein it
sicherheitsunternehmen und für sie ist
die lage klar denn schon im jahr 2007
hätten kollegen und kolleginnen die
malware identifiziert die sich
hauptsächlich gegen politische oder
militärische ziele richten
zitat diese software wurde offenbar über
einen längeren zeitraum entwickelt sie
wurde nicht für den einmaligen gebrauch
geschrieben das wertet sie als hinweis
darauf dass eine organisation dahinter
stecken muss ein festes team das immer
mit denselben werkzeugen zuschlägt und
langfristig plant möglicherweise auch
ein staatlicher akteur die daten
verraten zudem dass sie in der zeitzone
von moskau kontrolliert worden waren
nach galante spricht alles dafür dass
fans sie bier hinter all diesen
angriffen steckt expertinnen und
experten vermuten dass diese hacker
gruppe zudem enge verbindungen zu dem
russischen militär geheimdienst hat ein
fbi chef bezeichnete sie mehr als sehr
laut denn wenn sie bier macht sich
offensichtlich keine große mühe seine
aktivitäten zu verschleiern und genau
deswegen zweifeln manche experten
experten halten es für möglich dass
dabei wir völlig anderes unter falscher
flagge agiert doch was will russland
damit bezwecken was ist das langfristige
ziel der kreml regierung galante ist
sicher dass putin nicht nur zitat die
physische westliche dominanz sondern
auch die fähigkeit des westens globale
werte und normen zu definieren infrage
stellen will
zitat ende demnach sollen alle möglichst
bald an der liberalen westlichen welt
ordnung zweifeln und galante ist nicht
die einzige die das befürchtet nicht
umsonst hat die eu im jahr 2015 die
taskforce strategische informationen ost
ins leben gerufen mehr als 500
zuarbeiter der elf
kommunikationsexperten haben keine
geringere aufgabe als russische
falschmeldung zu entlarven eine ganze
fake news maschine im kreml also die
urheberschaft der russischen regierung
lässt sich zwar nie eindeutig nachweisen
doch die indizien sind erdrückend laut
experten nur experten tragen die
kampagnen die handschrift russischer
geheimdienste die jahrzehntelange
erfahrung mit versteckten operationen
sammeln konnten in vielen staaten von
osteuropa dem baltikum skandinavien bis
nach mitteleuropa gebe es gezielte
desinformations kampagnen da sind sich
experten und expertinnen sicher die
kernbotschaft sei immer gleich traue
niemandem
und wenn man die ganze feld novelle
sieht ist sogar us präsident donald
trump dieser kampagne aufgesessen
herzlichen glückwunsch
besser hätte es nicht laufen können der
in russland geborene sicherheits
analytiker anderson sagt klipp und klar
zitat das erste was man verstehen muss
ist dass das ein krieg ist das ist kein
witz und das ist kein spiel es geht
nicht um geselligkeit mit freunden den
sozialen netzwerken sogar die die nicht
teilnehmen wollen müssen sich nach den
gesetzen des krieges verhalten zitat
ende seiner meinung nach verwendet die
putin regierung methoden des kalten
krieges um die liberale demokratie der
westlichen welt zu sprechen
europäische wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sind mit dem begriff
krieg etwas vorsichtiger der politologe
simon hegele ich aus münchen spricht von
manipulation strategien die angewandten
strategien stamm seiner ansicht nach
zwar aus dem militärischen und dem
geheimdienst bereich seien aber aktuell
frei auf dem markt verfügbar vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch noch an die
verschwörungstheorien während des
amerikanischen wahlkampfes stichwort
pizza gate die cia habe julian assange
ermordet oder hillary clinton aber
packen sind oder was da alles wird
verbreitet worden war das alles
verunsichert die leute und könnte laut
ekelig dazu führen dass sie am ende
zitat nur noch einfache antworten von
populistischen parteien glauben
und wenn ein verwirrter sänger wie
xavier naidoo dann auch noch darauf
reinfällt das ist doch alles perfekt die
große und alles entscheidende frage am
ende sind wir dem ganzen einfach so
ausgeliefert das hängt wohl von der
aktuellen lage eines landes ab und der
stimmung der menschen täglich zufolge
sind die usa wohl anfälliger da das land
seit jahren gespalten und durch die
finanzkrise zusätzlich verunsichert sei
desinformation social bots und leaks
haben in deutschland dagegen wohl nicht
so einen großen einfluss das hat lisa
maria neu das vom oxford internet
institute zur festgestellt 4 bis 15
prozent der tweets die hier zur
landtagswahl im saarland und zur
bundespräsidentenwahl verbreitet worden
waren stammen ihrer analyse wohl von
automatisierten accounts in russland
seien bei politischen themen mit rund 40
prozent zu rechnen auch der fettanteil
sein deutschland geringer ihr rad eine
gesunde skepsis denn nicht alles was in
sozialen netzen wichtig ist entspricht
auch den realen interessen der menschen
ja ein absolutes thema da wird sicher
noch eine menge darüber zu erfahren
geben aber ich habe jetzt das
versprochene bulli für euch in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion von
technology review ist dieses video
entstanden und exklusiv für pixum
zuschauer gibt es ein geschenk ihr
bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn
er auf diesen link klickt es lohnt sich
kann ich nur sagen
technology review ist wirklich eine ganz
fantastische zeitschrift immer super
recherchiert wie auch dieses thema und
hier geht es zu einem weiteren video das
wir mit der redaktion gemacht haben
virtual reality verändert die welt
blickt drauf wenn es euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt kann